Hello everybody, sorry for the longer waiting screen, I was
sitting here trying to untangle my headphones.
My headphones, what I do is I usually just, I usually just,
I take them around my fingers and I go and then I have like
a little hanger.
that I hang them on?
And that's all I do.
And then I tried to get them on Tangle today.
And they were like, No.
No.
Invisible Booze.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
The headphones aren't used to the new cafe.
I wonder if they're melting.
Wow!
Lance, thank you so much.
For the pink.
Thank you so much.
Unleashed from the spaghetti.
Mmm, spaghetti.
Wow.
Why double pink?
I'm so excited.
You and Denso 2 are coming to my hometown for Moshi Expo.
Yes!
On top of heading to Off Kai to cheer you on at Legends of
New in two weeks.
Two weeks.
Two weeks, Gary.
My eyeball heart is fuller than ever, Denzatsu love MVP
forever!
MVP forever!
Yeah!
Thank you so much, Pakta.
Thank you!
See you at the Moshi Expo.
Yeah, actually two conventions got released.
Released?
Announced.
Two announcements got released recently.
In, uh, for Denzatsu appearances.
One is, uh, oh gosh, the name of the convention is escaping
me but it's in Singapore it's a new VTuber convention VTuber
centric convention in Singapore and then the other one is
Moshi Expo I believe that's V stage yes yes yes Mito please
come back to home Matt I would love to go back to home Matt
if they invite me back I would love to go I had so much fun
at home this is didn't sit having a bit of a world tour as
we do we gotta hit up every continent though baby Antarctica
cons rise up where are you at so excited to see you in
Sydney tomorrow yeah subculture V stage is the Singapore one
oh Thank you, thank you, Steiner.
Shouldn't?
What time is it over there?
Oh, it's like morning.
Okay, never mind.
Penguin Eye Boos.
Oh, imagine the smell.
They'd be so stinky.
They'd be so smelly.
But yes.
Today, I saw someone.
I don't know how...
how I don't know I only saw one person say it so I do not
know if I'm getting one guide hi Chuggy Grandango awake it
awakes extra childhood memories the voiceover in German
literally had the German voice of Alf in it wait that's so
funny I did say that somebody said that this chapter is a
little bit longer why peek why peekie for Minky okay for
skylight serenade it will be my first time going to a meet
of our concert ever okay no pressure no pressure then i will
do the bestest job ever um i've loved this grim playthrough
i hope you have fun too let's save manny glottis and meche
today yes thank you maflake thank you let's do that let's do
let's do let's do it's longer than three i think but it's
kind of split in the sections okay well let's do our best to
get through it I don't want to, uh, I, I don't want to waste
too much time, even though I want to yapp.
But there will be other chances to yapp.
Yes, yes, yes.
So, um, I actually did not save the game again after we went
up this area and saw that super sick train cutscene.
So we will be able to get to see it again.
For now, though, we have this.
I'm guessing this means up here.
know where does this where does this go but let's glottis
fell so let's go see if he's okay two-parter finale is fine
yeah we'll see how far we get and everything what are these
oh glottis would love these oh glottis the glottis who is
dead now where are you going manny Manny.
Nothing in the cap, a donut boxes, and coffee to go cups.
H-O-O-C-O-F-F-E-E-T-O-T-O.
You can take your coffee to go.
Time spent yapping is never wasted.
I agree with you.
But I also want to beat the game.
I also want to beat the game.
Oh my gosh.
One thing, though, is so exciting is every time I stream
now, Now, I'm like, oh my gosh, I'm one stream closer to my
new outfit debut on Wednesday.
I'm so excited, excited, excited.
Yeah, yeah.
I was playing with it today, and I was like, I was like it
in the mirror, and I'm just like, so cute.
six days remain not picking that up just pick up the whole
car just do it what is this thing like I know it's a coffin
but for who looks like standard DoD issue oh give me a break
those stairs are murder what's it oh yeah there you go Bruno
Bruno Martinez you you were the guy who packed me in there
you could have at least given me a magazine oh that's right
we put you in sand with nothing to read with this damn mug
oh sorry what are you doing here and if you were headed this
way why didn't you offer me a lift this world's for suckers
this is why we don't talk about bruno wait what's the mug
say world's best it's filled with the stuff though i got an
achievement i'm getting out of here world is for suckers i
drink it but i don't want to get a packing foam mustache he
put a valid crash out honestly it's so true though hello
they're empty hello hello oh no wait oh like uh but uh
please every time i try to click it hello hello they're
empty what Only Bruno's is, like, really fancy.
Glottis!
That's the road we came in on.
Nothing out there but snow and a perfectly good pair of
sunglasses.
What about the sunglasses?
I'd go crazy in a coffin for four years.
Manny!
What's wrong?
Go up there and see!
Oh.
We get called by Mente!
How long do they have to wait in there?
Until they have tickets.
is the really awesome cutscene on the number nine and they
don't have them now the punishment for selling double end
tickets is very severe but they didn't sell their tickets
their tickets were stolen by who hector leman stole them to
sell to rich people who don't deserve them yeah that might
be them now let's see just what they deserve god will judge
them the skelly train will them and determine okay you're
sipping on your little martini right now but you're you're
going you're taking one trip down down downtown baby
yeah also is that train like mega packed or am I crazy were
that was that like windows lining like people lining the
windows yeah excited for more grim fandango today thank you
counselor me too so let's talk to this guy now what happened
to that train what happened to that train your destiny
cannot be purchased so why i don't understand why has
everyone been detained given a ticket a soul may not sell it
no but they didn't sell it yeah sell their tickets someone
else is trying to bring the tickets that is all the tickets
are in El Maro the tickets are in El Maro how can I get
there quickly these rails are already there well thanks for
the help the gate opens the gate shut the gate closes it
does not help oh he's saying he won't help like the gate it
kind of looks like a booty like a, you know, like some
stylized butt cheeks on his, like, like it's a beautiful
buttocks facing, like, you know, like this is the back of
the person, not their booty sticking out, you know what I
mean?
Mate, okay, oh, where is everybody?
Wait, I thought this, I know they're detained, but like,
they're not even in a waiting area.
Is this where I came from?
Oh, um, oh my god, he's in!
Oh, he's in there!
stuck a little bit oh god are you okay
hey how'd you get free i was born free boat nick nobody gave
me no ticket so nobody can take it away so what are you
pacing around here for trying to unwind a little bit all
those years circling in one direction gotta even out my life
in this world before i go on to the next you know well that
ought to do her oh are you done?
You're heading out now?
Goodbye, Chapito.
Happy trails, Captain.
And thanks for setting me straight back there in the drink.
This little light of mine, I'm gonna let it shine.
Let it shine, let it shine, let it shine.
I eat it under some seaweed.
No, I'm gonna let it she's not even gonna take the trade.
Oh, Chapito.
Am I going to cry in this game?
This little light.
I like how he sang it off key.
I'm going to let it shine.
This little light of mine.
You cry at every game.
That's not true.
I feel like it's going to be really emotional.
I already feel like crying over Chapito.
for two seconds i could actually do it i could walk out of
this world right now and not look back but i can't i can't
do it i'm not leaving without the people i promised to save
oh hold to your commitments this achievement i just got he
was just circling in this little pond or not this pool this
kitty pool
this area is cool wait how do i get to the wait um maybe
this way there we go There's that door over there.
Oh, this is where I came from.
Wait, so where is everybody?
Meche called to me and now she's gone.
Did I miss something else?
I'm looking at the wall too.
Cool.
This little Ibu's gonna watch Minto shine.
This little mint of mine, I'm gonna let her shine.
This little mint of mine, I'm gonna let her shine, let her
shine, let her shine, let her shine.
All right, I guess we go this way then.
Whoa.
Does he have anything else to tell me?
Well, thanks for the help.
The gate opens.
Oh, yeah.
The gate closes.
It does not help.
well well it's not that I'm afraid or anything but there are
easier ways into the station and I'm not walking back to El
Maro oh well then we're at the station what do we do we wait
for do we wait for the train sit and wait I tried looking
for glottis oh wait there was that one way that I was that
kind of confused me let's go recently i was visited by a
bird with a human head do you know such a bird manuel
calavera no how do you know my he knew you and for you he
left this oh note a note
i know what you're up to i've been watching stay there i'm
coming to sprout you myself yours truly Hector Le Mans,
Icholi.
What?
That's terrifying.
There was this one.
It kind of confused me.
Oh.
What is happening?
Oh, Grand Demonio Roydor.
Why are the minions working on Gwadis?
The name of the great one.
Glottis.
What's happening?
How many days has this Grand Demon without driving.
Many, many, many.
But we've been hiking for months.
Months?
Oh, then the noble ones will surely die.
No, he won't!
He had to drive.
No, he can still drive!
Stick him in the seat!
He'll return to his senses!
Hey, I'm on a gondola ride, Grimlins.
He's too big.
The gondola is too slow.
No, no, no.
Meiji, we have to get back to Amaro for the tickets.
Oh, Gladys.
Gladys?
Gladys, I'm sorry.
Why didn't you tell me you were sick?
Couldn't stop, have to save everyone.
Please don't lie, Gladys!
How can I get you?
Will anything help?
to race to fly like like the old days manny in the bone
wagon but the bone wagon's not here carnal maybe i'll see
her on the other side no we're gonna we're gonna save
glottis i believe i believe i believe can we yeah we make a
new hot rod those days are done manny no more hot right hey
what's that red thing the gondola glottis is really ride or
die sweet decal work listen fellas somebody somebody get a
pen a pen is there it is my final work it could save me if
you have the right the right you're what fuel glottis
glottis No!
Gladys, what fuel?
Oh, no, no.
He needs the juiced up stuff.
Meche, we have to get back.
Oh, okay.
Oh, he needs the juiced up stuff.
Oh, Glottis.
He is so dramatic.
It looks like blueprints for a rocket sled.
They're brilliant.
I mean, Glottis is brilliant.
That's my god.
That's our god.
What's in here?
What's this say?
Your mother doesn't work here.
Since nobody listened to my last warning about keeping this
refrigerator clean, I'm afraid I'm going to have to lock it
until some of you grow up.
Signed, the facilities department.
Your mother doesn't work here.
It's so funny.
Wait, can I take it?
Can I take it?
Can I take the toaster?
Toaster tiny English muffins in.
Oh, good question.
Can I use the toaster?
And drink!
What a way to start a notice.
For real.
What if my mom does work here?
You don't know.
You don't know anything about me.
So we can't get in the fridge.
Wait, what's this?
It's the mug rack at the end of the world.
Wait!
I kind of want a mug rack.
I have so many mugs that I like to show off.
I'm going to write that down.
Get a mug rack.
That's so cute.
What's this?
Oh, nothing.
What's in here?
It's closed.
Then open it, Bozo.
It's full of rags.
Take one.
Take a rag.
What was a good idea to have a clean rag around?
What if it's a dirty rag?
What's in here?
Nothing.
okay maybe we've gotten everything can I take the mug wrap
I've already got a mug and quite a handsome one at that I
might add wait can we put the mug on the mug rack
I hate it when people leave their crusty mugs out in the
break room you are the one who put it there what are we
talking about do you want to wash it first I don't what do
you mean can I use this on the mug rack on the mug What does
it say?
Oh, today is the first day of the rest of your life.
It's the mug I gave Bruno and it's full of that foam I
packed him in.
Rarely have I seen a bigger hypocrite.
That's what I'm saying.
It's a lovely rag.
I know what you're up to.
I've been watching.
Stay there.
I'm coming to sprout you myself.
truly Hector Lamont's when he says it it queues the music
again that's so funny wait let me put the mug there for now
let me put the mug there
I hate it when people leave their crusty mugs shut up in the
break room well it's good to know they recycle oil out here
at the end of the world my joints don't need any oiling
right now what's over here how eerie they have the same tool
cabinets Eerie.
Not picking that up.
What's in there?
How eerie?
They lock up their tools just like Lottis.
How is that eerie?
Maybe it's like those black and yellow totes that you can
get.
I didn't know those were so popular.
Then you start seeing them everywhere.
And then you see that they...
But did you ever see that they made mini black and yellow
totes?
Like the famous black and yellow totes?
They made mini versions of them.
Can I ride this thing?
Hey, how about a gondola ride, Grimlins?
He's too big.
The gondola is too slow.
Okay.
Maybe there's something down here.
What are totes?
Like the big tote...
crate, tote crates, the big, the big, the big, yeah, the
Costco totes.
There's giant tote crates.
How do you say?
Costco totes.
Am I saying it wrong?
No, I'm not.
The Costco storage bin, storage Costco gallon bin.
27 gallon storage totes.
the totes.
They're so cheap and they're so famous.
They're big famous totes.
They're big famous storage totes.
They're green made 27 gallons storage totes.
27 gallons of all tote and storage.
Black and yellow, yellow, black.
27 gallons One tote with lid $6.99 $6.99 For a big old tote
How eerie Mint is reading my super chat Just like Glottis
Where are you going that Glottis is reading your super chats
I'll be there every day Why do you keep saying it like that?
Saying it like what?
27 gallon storage totes.
The storage totes.
The heavy duty storage tote bins at Costco.
The Costco yellow top bin, storage bin, storage Costco
gallon bins at Costco.
Green made 27 gallon storage totes.
You're saying totes with an English accent.
No, I'm not.
I'm saying totes.
Is that how it's pronounced?
What do you mean?
I'm saying it with an English.
I'm saying it's horrible.
Tencent who come get your girl, she's stuck on repeat.
What are we talking about?
They're totes.
There's gotta be something in here.
It's a car.
It's gotta have the fuel.
Hello?
That's the road we came in on.
Was there anything else I missed?
Totes, but goats.
We went over there.
Nothing here, nothing there.
And upwards.
I've always referred to them as storage containers, never
totes.
Well, today, you can start calling them totes too.
Well, it's not that I'm afraid or anything, but there are
easier ways into the station.
Hush, hush, hush.
And I'm not walking back to Elmorrow.
Hmm.
Is this not the fuel?
Oh, this is oil, right?
I can't talk to these guys.
They don't want to talk to me.
Gladys, what fuel?
Can I take it?
Hey, can I see those for a second?
Please.
This is mechanics work.
It looks like blueprints for a rocket sled.
They're brilliant.
Where's that shadow coming from?
I think it's...
I've wondered that this one down here, right?
I think it's me.
Oh, wait.
No, it's not.
Who is it?
Oh, wait.
Who's shadow is it?
It's not Meche.
Is it?
Let's see.
Maybe it...
Oh, maybe it is her.
Maybe it's just like a really strange shadow.
Of hers.
Maybe it's her and the gremlin combined, and that's why it's
so bizarre looking.
So we got a rag.
Um...
What if I...
What if I wipe off his...
What if I wipe his design?
The
mood to dust.
What the heck?
What?
Can I help?
I'm sure someone around here is paid to clean these.
Hmm.
What can we use this for?
Evil.
Maybe I'll do some dusting later.
Can we get this?
This better not stay in my pocket.
Can we give it to him?
Maybe he smells it and he says, that's the fuel.
Here, Cardinal.
Get away for this.
Oh, that's nice.
Make sure to...
Lay some of those on my grave, will you, Manny?
Gladys, no!
I'll oil stuff later.
Once Gladys is okay.
Can I oil this?
I'm no gondola gunkerupu.
Gunkerupu?
Wait, what about the car down here?
Oh, wait.
Is there, um, maybe...
Maybe I can use it on this?
I'll oil stuff later.
Once Gladys is okay.
Oh, why am I doing that?
Oh!
That's our fuel, baby!
That's our fuel!
What was in that mug?
Something that powerful could fuel a...
A rocket!
If only we had more.
The foam!
Well, I could score you a couple of truckloads if you're
interested.
We shoot you now like an arrow into the wind.
May you pierce the heart of the wind itself and drink the
blood of flight.
Drink the blood of flight.
The Food of the Great Glotis.
Speed brings you light.
Speed is the Food of the Great Glotis.
Go!
Glotis go!
Amidro my demon don't die, let's go!
No!
He's alive!
Speed is the Food of the Great Demon!
Glotis!
He's feeling it, he's eating it, he's tasting the blood of
speed.
You sure this thing's going to hold together?
Uh, at least most of the way.
Hey, look.
We're all ready to Rubikava.
Oh no, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
I don't want to be in Rubikava, please.
Manny, where are you?
Manny, I'm thriving!
Oh no!
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh, wait, that was so sudden.
No, no, get me out of here, please.
No, God, please, God, no, no, no, get me out of, no, get me
out of Rubik's Cava.
No, no, that's all over here.
Ah, Rubikava, what a town.
Remember the glory days, Manny?
Long gone, my friend.
There's nothing here for us now.
Except maybe our old car.
Oh.
Dios mio She's been booby trapped Why who Why what the heck
is this?
Oh who could it be The line of dominoes I wonder
Those dominoes Are like one long fuse Who could it be Can I
take them I don't think my hands are steady enough for that
I'm not setting foot down there the slightest bump could
start those Domino's tumbling I'm not sitting foot down
there the slightest bump could start those Domino's tumbling
don't panic this is quite impressive I want it would be even
more impressive if it spelled out a threat to man you know
but Domino's dead looks like Domino left guard but how I saw
him torn to shreds he must have done this on his last trip
through town oh what's that is this a shovel that's the
folding bridge that connects this pier to the base of the
cat track do we want to go there oh no the cat track please
God is that why this level is so long because I have to go
back through every maintenance has gotten pretty lax around
here apparently maybe not how
much is still around I wonder is I mean, it's been, what?
Two years?
No?
Remember, it's not Tuesday, so the kitty cat hats aren't
available.
It's still the stupid music.
But you're a loser music.
It was Domino Pizza's those feeds.
They do good to limit your screens to relevant areas.
Okay, that's good, then.
Oh!
No!
No way.
Is this guy...
He's still...
Oh, oh, I thought it was the other guy that was still
asleep.
No, I don't want to disturb his grumpy little dreams.
I'm opening this up.
I don't want to wake up Toto.
Okay, okay.
Stop moving.
I think these are binders of tattoo design.
I don't want to wake up Toto.
You're not going to wake him up just by...
I wonder if Inez has cooled off yet.
We're talking about Inez?
Hello, operator?
Yeah, it's me, Manny.
I was just passing through town.
I don't want to wake up.
I don't want to wake up total.
He's still mad.
Talks very loudly on the phone.
I couldn't hear anything over that guy's snoring, though.
Everybody has a snoring problem, it seems.
It's hard to see, but there's a cabinet on the wall.
There is in there.
I don't want to go back, though.
Hopefully though it's not like a...
Hopefully it's not a...
I don't want to wake up toto thing again.
There was a dude... Oh my god.
Oh, it's infuriating.
Oh, I see it.
Thank you.
Oh my god, please.
There was a guy on the flight back from AX who snored like
that for five hours.
There can't be too much in here.
I better save it.
What is it?
Shut your hole.
What did you get?
Can we use it on him?
Is it poison?
There can't be too much in here.
I'd better save it.
What is it?
Oh my god, get me out of here.
Color cost more.
No, please.
What is it?
Liquid nitrogen, not to be used on bone.
I almost killed that guy!
Permanently!
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
How did we get Meche to be not locked up?
They're also... hold on.
This we couldn't open before, but now I'm wondering if for
some reason we can.
locked but there's nothing up there anyway that goes to the
upper dock but nothing's docked there now oh it was the are
you wait maybe we need to take the blimp though
no bees anymore I like how everything looks this oh no it's
still up there what do you mean there's nothing there
anymore I like how that
lady She got sprouted.
Yeah, the place hasn't changed at all, really.
Even this thing is still here.
They haven't...
Oh, they never finished the other one, I guess.
Hmm, not a good sign for Rubikaba's organized labor
movement.
Yeah.
Hello, Terry?
Hmm.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
we can go into the blue casket again oh it's dead where did
everybody go
oh what is this coffin shooter one two three just pour chill
and serve I would but I hate sucking gelatin straight from
the tap I don't need the hernia nothing in the dishwasher
anything in here they still haven't done these I'm not gonna
eat off of dirty plates I'm not asking you to eat and I'm
not going to clean them okay okay nothing in the dishwasher
but still they left the dirty dishes hello Vera what are you
doing here I heard you went pow and Zapato daddy well Hector
Lamont's tried and missed now it's my turn I'm headed to El
Maro to put them out of business yeah manny that place has
changed you don't know what you're getting into i'd better
come with you just give me a minute to get ready okay but if
you hear a loud explosion anytime soon the trip's off okay
awesome okay we're gathering our party for our this is
becoming a jrpg or something wait can i still do poem i just
can't do it without an audience oh come on the audience who
do it for the love of the game what are we talking about
here oh my gosh he's chasing after that fame and glory let's
go up it's locked what oh no wait but what about the guy who
what's about the mortician man um what else was around here
we came from this way what was over here oh this is where
the dock was oh Manuel Calavera well what happened to the
limbo hate to tell you Velasco but she went down at the
pearl but we found a new ship the SS La Mancha and managed
to the La Mancha my old rusty bucket where is she oh well we
traded her in Puerto Zapato for a team sled dogs does it I'm
out of this stinking mob town but thanks for finding my baby
manny where does it bother here I come mob town mob town
what's happening here but also um what was I gonna say I
thought because we became captain what happened like why did
why did he stop being the captain you think after two years
he'd have the little SS Lumbago's lifeboats on at least what
is this maybe I'll just finish this for him I drink it but I
probably get the SS Lumbago stuck in my throat all right
we're taking more stuff awesome click the mood I was going
to you could say please your manners but we have no partner
to sing it it's shown pale as bone as I stood there alone
and I thought to myself how the moon that night cast its
light on my heart's true delight and the reef where her body
was strewn ah not quite the same with that old Velasco not
quite the same not quite the same can we go up there anyway
I know there's no boat dock it's locked locked I have a
question was locked was that was that Blade Runner?
Was that when I played the Blade Runner game?
I can't remember what point and click.
I'm mixing up on my point and clicks now.
It was, wasn't it?
Okay.
Whacked.
Oh.
Uh.
This music is different.
Is it because we're a mob town now?
Nancy Drew also said it.
But the guy in Blade Runner said it very specifically.
He went,
Like it was spelled to him, L-A-H-K-E-D, you know what I
mean?
Lacked.
I don't really, I can't remember where to go, how to get
back.
Is it this one?
Yes.
So we can't go up to the kitty cats.
now I think wait this is whoa you'd think after two years
he'd have the little SS Lumbago's lifeboats on at least oh
this is it sounds like there's water in there but it's the
model ship I was like did we take like a alcohol or
something yeah it's the ship in the bottle yeah yeah yeah it
makes like a drinky sound there we're like it's a bottle
whatever maybe we use these liquid nitrogen it would just
evaporate what a I don't really want to do that what can I
do with it this time?
Pretty sure you do not have to go back to the Snorville at
least.
That's a relief.
I think it's the nitrogen bottle making that sound.
No, it's even when I take out the...
The model, though.
Glottis.
There's... It's so funny the way he, like, freezes and
stares.
Like, they didn't give him any sort of, like, idle
animation.
Like...
I think everyone else kind of, like, at least sways or like
does something eventually but glottis is always just
he's at peace inside i'm so jealous of him
trying to think of what else there is to do well let's try
this i guess i don't know why but I try you try everything I
don't want to mess up my blade okay I don't remember if we
talked to me you really should get back in case it blows I'm
with you guys till the end you know that can I wait it says
there's nothing up there but like
There can't be too much in here.
I'd better save it.
No.
There can't be too much in here.
I didn't think that would work, but I'm also not quite sure.
Oh, see, this thing's still up there.
There's stuff up there to go see.
No?
Oh, wait.
His little wiggling ears.
I'm trying to see if there's anything that we can...
I think I tried everything that...
I think Gladys has to say.
He just goes, yeah.
Don't panic.
Save reminder, thank you.
We shall save, we shall save.
Like a tree I'm stumped.
Me too.
I didn't...
It didn't seem like there was much else to go to around here
unless I'm...
There was the lock on the elevator.
Maybe I need to go up.
Hmm.
He's frozen in fear.
His little ears are so cute.
The barrel in the kitchen really stood out since it wasn't
there before.
That is very true.
There might be something in there that we know.
do need it's locked it's locked hmm wait
I've already interacted with the last piece I need is it the
barrel then are we gonna are we gonna do Indiana Jones style
survive the nuclear bomb with a refrigerator there can't be
too much in here I better save it what about you oh now it's
sloshing that's what the lumbago diorama needed fake ocean
water what color is that oh very blue don't panic but
there's this really cute ghost girl on the right of your
screen me yeah don't panic there might be a spooky ghost
haunting your computer right now.
A ghost in the machine, if you will.
Oh, the blue gelatin.
Yeah, that's...
He did mention it was like a jello, huh?
Yay!
Oh!
So then, now he said the other thing would evaporate.
Now it won't evaporate if it's just the...
You know.
Right?
I don't really want to do that.
No, are you sure?
I'd drink it, but I'd probably get the SS Lumbago stuck in
my throat.
What throat?
I'm gonna use it on.
What's that?
It's, uh, Lumbago Lemonade.
Try it.
Oh.
A perky little aperitif, actually.
Yes, sirree.
Not bad tall.
Tell me where you got that right now!
Olivia's kitchen.
Lumbago!
Lambeid!
Manny, aren't we in a hurry?
Don't worry, this won't take long.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh no!
No!
My stomach don't stretch like it used to.
Oh, Glottis.
Glottis, don't do it.
Glottis, don't hurl now.
So what is that stuff they pack canned hams in anyway?
Oh, gross!
Gladys!
You can't hold your lemonade now!
Oh, oh, it just doesn't stop.
Oh, good lord.
Good show, my friend.
You wouldn't happen to have a breath mint on you, I suppose.
I don't like that.
You just happen to have a breast mint on you, I suppose.
Ew, Kwanis.
I don't want to go back in there.
Oh, he's so very neatly covered the floor, actually.
Yahoo!
Hey, good idea.
I bet I could keep it down now that it's cold.
Just let me get across for a minute.
okay don't try it again I better disarm her first oh okay
you're right wait I'm gonna save just in case we die here
for some reason I think I would never but you never know
well here goes nothing there goes nothing we got it looks
like Hector's taking over the whole town.
Holy cow!
He hasn't had much resistance.
There's only one small group who oppose him, and they live
out on the fringes of the city.
What the?
Places like this, you mean?
I hope they're not hurting, Gladys.
Huh.
Show's what you know about this group.
Their leader is a great man who...
Hey!
It's us!
Hi!
I see you have found what you were looking for.
I'm fortunate for you to arrive now, just as we two are
about to achieve success.
our army has grown and right now our top agents are in
Hector's weapons lab about to close in the weapons lab then
I couldn't have done it without you Manuel trap no it was a
trap it was a trap stand back there's only one thing to do
oh my God like you sir you have saved me but more than that
you have enabled me to continue to serve the movement what
did you say about a trap Hector uncovered our agent in his
weapons lab no we were just on the verge of greatness wait
so you can stop the spread of the you idiot falsely your new
lab assistant is a spy have you ever heard of a background
check he like shoots them in the foot and then like likes to
watch them be sprouted what no time to explain now I'll have
to take matters into my own hands take me with you whoa I've
longed to be of service to your cause for years oh yeah cuz
she's like a little poet freak gotta savor the deed exactly
that's so cool though you can stop it's like a poison almost
but neat you can you can save them what's going on here
me too glottis glottis fourth wall break
yeah like a zombie but it's the part of that soldier that
didn't get up and hop out of here on one hand better save
this part from sprouting oh what did i thank you sir wait
wait i want to see you do it over here Thank you, sir.
Eva!
Any messages for me?
Nope.
Calls stop coming for you the day you left.
They're still sending you that Lagerie catalog, though.
Oh, what?
I never...
What?
Why would I need that?
Do you have them so I can double check if they were
necessary?
Doug Robertson thank you so much for that bit we kicked it
thank you so so much holy cow thank you thank you so much
this camera is showing nothing but flowers must be another
fallen agent no this one too this camera sprouted as well
that's three LSA casualties in one night oh who's the plant
nut that nut is is Hector Lamont's personal munitions
expert, Bowlesley, AKA the florist.
That was his job in the old world, but here he is a
botanical weapons expert.
This has left him fairly conflicted.
Why does he make Sproutella for Hector instead of our side?
We've been trying to recruit him for years, but his lab is
in Hector's tower.
He's untouchable.
Oh, interesting.
Thank you for the years of joy.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for 23 months, almost two whole years.
Thank you, thank you!
Come here, little manny.
Ow!
Hey!
Must be little Mitchie.
Already got some.
Get some.
What's that?
Are you two?
No?
Not again.
Are we back?
Sorry, I looked over my...
I looked like my OBS glitched.
Sorry about that.
Someone gifted me a membership to this cute ghost big girl
win!
Thank you!
Congrats!
We're back, we're back?
What did we miss?
I reached in the trash can.
I noticed it went, I noticed things went down so I, uh...
I grabbed something.
What did I grab?
Thank you so much for the fight!
Get there!
Thank you!
What did we grab?
Oh!
I bet the agent in this photo is the poor guy that Hector
just shot.
Oh, that's what I grabbed from the trash.
Can we pet the pigeon?
I did.
He bit our finger.
Wait, what's the...
Oh, this is us talking to you.
Mitten!
Okay, here's the plan.
I need a disguise so I can get close to Hector.
And a gun, so we'll have something to talk about when I get
there.
If you figure out that part, I'll go find out where he is.
His casino tower is directly above these hedges.
quarters oh all right meet me there oh okay volunteers
quickly for dangerous work she could be very useful to the
cause as far as I'm concerned she is the cause whoa what are
these so you think I'm down here either memo to all agents
priority urgent in light of the recent disappearances all
agents are ordered to avoid travel in unlit areas until
further notice memo to all in In light of the recent
disappearances, all agents are ordered to avoid travel in
unlit areas until further notice.
All right, let's save real quick because we had a little bit
of an issue.
Oh, oh, we can't talk to Glottis.
He's doing his thing again.
He's doing his little, his role-playing.
Oh
my god, who's down there?
Let's see, what else?
This feels...
This part feels extremely blade runner now, doesn't it?
Whoa.
There's so many holes.
Maybe I have to go through the right one to get to.
How about this one?
Anyone down here?
Monsters, again?
Can anyone hear me besides the scary monster?
Dang.
Dang!
Go to space.
Sleeve sewer thing.
Close your big clave blind eyes.
Clave blind eyes.
Okay, I don't know what's down there, but I have issues with
it.
Me too.
Clave blind.
They couldn't do a second take on that one.
let's see let's go up to the daisy oh what a thrill with
darkness and silence through the night what a thrill casino
don't don't show don't show glottis I'm searching oh wow
this one's even more I'm searching and I'll to you what a
fear in my heart that's our outfit baby it's not like Johnny
Thunder let's just anybody in this review no I mean being
allowed to wear the Johnny Thunder makeup is an honor yes so
I said to her you give me that 10% discount or I'm taking my
business elsewhere you said that well oh yes i was mad you
know and then here's the good part yeah what's the oh no
what's the good part oh are you here for the thunder boy
tryouts yes yes i am oh that's too bad because we just got
the last two parts maybe next season well i guess so do i
have a yeah no no come on man you know you want to do it
hey get lost pal no autographs i'm ready to kill for those
parts
let the intrusive thoughts win what if i show them this hand
and be like this is gonna be you hey get lost pal no
autographs bye
Hmm, show business coffee.
Show business coffee.
Wait, what if I put it back?
Wait a second.
There can't be too much in here.
Maddie!
Oh, coffee, great.
Oh.
His mug materialized.
About time we got a PA around here.
Hey, kid, keep it black and keep it coming, all right?
Wow.
Okay, so we definitely got to do something with the coffee.
Yeah.
Of course, as soon as I save up enough money for a double-in
ticket, I'm out of here.
What?
You can't just buy a double-in?
Well, I know somebody who knows somebody who knows...
Hector Lamont's.
you knew everybody no kidding hey out of the dressing room
we got all the Thunder boys we need Bobby so then I says
Hector Lamar's all right heading back down let's go to the
casino then so we got to get maybe dressed up as one of them
I assume got to figure out some way to pretty face before I
hit the streets.
That's fair.
You're pretty, pretty face.
Yeah.
I think there was some place else we could go to.
Put ectoplasm in the coffee.
They wouldn't be seeing straight for weeks.
Months.
Absolute psychosis.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, did I go this way oh this was yeah the sewer pipes
what can we put in the coffee what did this say again I know
what you're up to I've been watching stay there I'm coming
to sprout you myself yours truly Hector Lamont's what if I
give them this letter and they're just like oh I don't
really have anything to go in the coffee though.
Wait, I don't mean to alarm you, but there is in fact
another ladder.
Wait, I missed one?
Did I?
Where did I miss it?
You good, buddy?
This one.
Keep going up.
Okay.
What a thrill.
I'm certain I'm melting to you.
Since he knows and knows and knows and knows a man that
knows and knows Hector LeMines, maybe he's just like, I know
what you're up to.
Hector LeMines.
Hey, get lost, pal.
No autographs.
I think this is something I should keep to myself.
Okay.
There's another lap.
Oh, up there!
I see it.
Oh!
What is this?
This snowmaker is huge, but the grinder part looks handheld.
Aha!
It's a handheld grinder.
What am I grinding?
I think he'd be happy to know his body was serving the cause
like this.
But I need to do something else with it.
Maybe.
This is kind of messed up.
This is kind of horrific, maybe.
I don't think it got in the coffee, right?
Mmm, show business coffee.
Maybe, do I need to take it up there, too?
This coffee's already ground.
Hmm.
Aww.
Can you take the grinder?
I don't think so.
Let me see.
Wait.
Take it?
Oh, I can!
I can!
Oh, nice.
Oh, this is horrible.
This is so disgusting.
I think show people prefer it black.
Oh, they did say that, huh?
Wait, no.
Oh, crap.
Hey, get lost, pal.
No autographs.
Oh,
oops.
Oh, God, I'm just...
I think so people prefer it black.
Hmm.
No autograph.
Yeah, I'm just grinding it all over the place.
Oh, oops.
I wonder, though, if there's something else I need to do
with this guy.
I feel
like it has to do with the coffee, though.
Has to do.
Right.
Oh, all right, fine.
One hour, six minutes catapultism.
Is it?
Does this guy like the bone?
Does this guy want a bone?
It's a bone chipper now.
Oh.
The music is so sad.
I don't know what's down there, but I have issues with it.
You haven't eaten him yet.
Who are we eating?
Don't want bone in their coffee.
They do not want coffee and bone.
The sequel to Netflix and Jill.
But...
Can he interact with the corpse in the office?
You can.
Wait, am I gonna like sprout them?
Wait.
It's so annoying though having to go up and down these.
Keeping the timer running since no one's drank yet.
We run a fair show here, everybody.
Oh gosh, these ladders are so annoying.
If he wants his own body seasoning.
He wants the seasoning of his body.
He wants to be salted.
Would you like to be salted?
I'm just spraying remains on everybody.
Wait, what is this?
No, stop, stop.
Stop doing that, Manny.
Good.
Eva finally got that radio work.
Shh, shh, shh, shh.
Calling all cars, calling all cars.
Manuel, is everything okay?
Uh, uh, just testing the equipment, Salvatore.
Salvador, maybe you should shut that thing off.
So we can talk.
They're together.
Why are they together?
The rest of him has gone to seed already.
Uh...
I don't feel like there's anything left in here.
Any messages from me?
Nope.
Calls stop coming for you today.
They're still sending you that Lagerie catalog, though.
Such great business, people.
Olivia's been a bit too femme fatale.
You think?
Is she gonna betray him?
Been to quit assaulting them.
I love that they didn't clean up the flower covered corpse
well is it I mean like the guy lived because they he just
severed the bones that were gonna get sprouted you know so
you know do they need to cover it up now it's a little
indoor garden I do say I do and I did and I will say guys
you gotta try this it's amazing I think show people prefer
it black they don't know they don't they don't see hey get
lost pal no autographs I'm
just watering the plants maybe if I do hey get lost pal no
autographs maybe if I do it like this manually I
think show people prefer it black hey
out of the dressing room we got all the thunder hey get lost
pal no autographs what are you trying to accomplish here
anyway well that's the fun thing about these types of games
is you don't ever know nope once you grind bone you can't go
back to fake snow nope once you grind bone you can't go back
to fake snow
Because sometimes things are just so...
Ludacris that you're like, why was this even an answer?
Classic words to live by.
What if I put coffee in the...
in here instead?
We'll make coffees now.
This coffee's already ground.
Oh, that's right, you said that before.
I feel like I need a hint, though.
like glottis vomit being an answer for a domino bomb yeah
the obvious answer the one that literally everyone would
think of you haven't tried giving them coffee yes i have i
literally did that and he was like keep it black and keep it
coming oh coffee great unless they ask for now they want
cream we'll see
it's about time so what did you i see him so i said
you don't say oh coffee great more coffee keep them coming
they said keep them coming they said
Can he pour it over them from the scaffold?
It's about time.
I don't think so.
We could try.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I didn't even see that.
Oh, what did you do that for?
I didn't.
Oh, I didn't even see that.
I can't go on like this.
I took you under my wing.
And this is how you pay me back.
Slap him.
No, no, it's not like that.
Wow, thank you for the, for that.
I didn't even see this little area.
I was too busy, busy, focusing on the grinder itself.
I don't know if this is still the thing that we need to do,
but we'll try.
I think show people prefer it black.
There's nothing here still.
Hey kid, this is your lucky day.
We got an opening and you're the newest Thunderboy in the
Johnny Thunder review.
Yes, I've been working for this moment all my life.
Me with a sit on down.
We got to start your makeup.
Me holding this Skelly hand.
You don't go too far.
You never know what time is showtime around here.
Bye.
Thunder, thunder, thunder cats.
Oh, secret door.
Cool.
Thunder, thunder, thundercats.
How?
I can't remember the last time I had access to a man's room.
What did you do before then?
Why do you need access?
The casinos are hot, baby.
Wait, we recognize this guy.
Going up?
This elevator goes up straight.
to the penthouse suite of Hector Lamans.
Mr. Lamans, he only do the business with the very select
elite clientele.
Oh, I see.
Let's go, there's like, this guy is an alien.
This guy is not a skeleton.
And this guy is invisible?
We have an actual bot?
Wait.
No drinks for me, thanks.
Wait, isn't this Oh, the guy from our club!
Missamid, Mint Phantom.
You should watch your step closely, or this game's puzzles
will leave you tired sorely.
So says Mr. Stewart.
Oh, I thought this guy was a robot.
Hey, what's going on under that rake coat?
I don't know what's going on under that makeup.
Agent Calavera!
Didn't Salvador chop you in half early this evening?
Yes, which has given me this glorious opportunity to serve
the cause, by gathering funds for the LSA while stealing
from her arch enemy at the same time.
Is it... wait, who... is this... who is this guy?
He did learn to do that quickly.
Hola!
No drinks for me, thanks.
recognize me i have no idea who i am except that one guy who
knew i can't go strolling through the halls now i'm on the
lamp that one guy who knew exactly who i was wait what if we
do this we know this guy so what if um
He's the one that...
What did he have in there?
Like, it was a bunch of money, right?
Maybe we show him this.
That's no way to treat an agent of the LSA.
Should we show the guy his hand?
Hey, buddy, look at this.
Wait, what did he just do?
Oh.
I
think you can still talk to Meche.
Buenos dias.
Back off, Slee's baller.
My husband here will bust your jaw.
what the wait is that not Mitchie are we oh we're all in a
we're all in cahoots together and stuff I think this is
something I should keep to myself I think this is something
I should keep to myself talk to her again it's so hard to
make sure it's me Manny here help me get mr.
high roller here into this sheet so we can get out of here
Oh
He's a ghost Is that you young lady?
I'll get you Not funny Young lady
Not right now.
Oh for crying out loud.
It won't let me do anything with them I'm going to punt this
twerp the first chance Yeah!
Let's hold on.
Oh, we gotta do it again.
You must be patient, my king.
Oh, dang it.
I'll escort you to your party just as soon as my system pays
off here.
I think I had a feeling it would be like...
Oh, wait.
No drinks for me, thanks.
I'm gonna try other items.
Why do you want to get them into a sheath?
I told him there was a big TOEFL party at the Casino Romano.
But he had to wear this sheet to get in.
After he changes, you take his suit and go upstairs.
Get it?
Oh, okay.
Then let's do it.
Let me...
Oh, thank you.
Let's do it, let's do it.
Mmm, you're trickier than I thought.
Wait!
Not again.
I'll get you.
I have to do something with him.
Lady.
What if I grind him?
Oh, for crying out loud.
Uh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Uh.
Talk to the arm guy.
What exactly are you doing with these slot machines?
Oh, I, well.
He's like going and hacking.
them it looks like I'll stick myself inside like a finger
down the third effective demons himself and I'll make the
machine regurgitate the wealth it has devoured yeah you must
be patient my kitten I'll escort you to your party just as
soon as my system pays off here talk
to this guy first more there's a machine over here that
seems unbeatable we're
talking to him that one with the sucker planted in front
tell me when he gives up and I'll make a cough cold change
oh maybe he gives up when we cover it up let's do it again
hey come on you see the party's moving on to the casino
Romano orale I'm not leaving until this fat lady sings no
one-armed bandit can outsmart chow chila Charlie I didn't
mean I know this guy he can play the slots for days I was
trying to talk to my team he'll come with me sing you
calling me the fat lady get you come on special assignment
just in from Salvador cracked that machine and leave the
change right away Yes, sir!
Yes, sir!
Yeah!
Get in there.
I like the way he just like crawls in, that's so funny.
Yippee!
We're rich!
I did it!
My system worked.
I knew it.
I told you.
Oh, you didn't even take the cash.
Now let's go so you can buy me a drink at the Romano.
I'll meet you at the train station with the tickets.
There won't be one from me, so you'll have to go back by
yourself.
I'll tell that gatekeeper everything.
He has to help us.
He doesn't have to do anything.
Come, my lovely.
I have another infallible system I'd like to demonstrate.
Ow.
No.
Ew.
Okay, let's save right there.
So we don't have to witness that again.
All right, now we're in our fancy clothes.
So what, we just go up?
What does that sound?
Nothing.
I'm select, and I'm very elite.
You look like you work in a meatlacker to me, pal.
These aren't my regular clothes.
Well, then you get your regular clothes.
I'll give you the regular treatment.
No.
Is the suit in there?
Oh, I forgot to change, huh?
I forgot to change, huh?
Oh, there we go.
A little tight in the shoulders, but at least it doesn't
wreak of sled dog.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm not going up there unarmed.
Oh.
sure wait can we I guess he doesn't want to go out wait I
just saw one I just saw a little arrow this one no okay
never mind step back this way we have to get a weapon
I don't think there was anything else down here was there
turns out his infallible system is a timeshare pyramid
scheme for cat cafe go figure
just all the issue of the dark tunnels okay okay i did
figure we would have to do that well rather i didn't know i
mean obviously i figured we would have to do that but i
didn't know if it would be before or after okay the dark
tunnels the dark tunnels it has to be the wait what if we
like make it sneeze listen you know check this out we make a
sneeze okay I don't know what's down there but I have issues
with it Dang.
That was my thought.
Can I drop this into there?
Drop this into the holes?
There can't be too much in here.
I'd better save it.
He's probably going to save that for Arby.
There can't be too much in here.
I'd better save it.
I'm going to save it.
There can't be too much in here.
Not that I'm going to take this puzzle really bad.
I don't have much on me.
You know?
Was a good plan, you thought so?
Yeah, made sense to you.
I thought so, too.
It seems like a very point-and-click game type answer, no?
Make the...
Make the guy sneaks.
Easy peasy.
Has to be at least one bad, really bad puzzle in a
point-and-click game.
Yeah.
Just one.
I swear you can get Glottis to help you here.
Let's try it.
If he'll let me talk to him.
You know?
If he's not too busy.
Oh.
He might be a little busy.
He might be.
Attack?
Wait, what about in here?
This one also was growling at me, wasn't it?
Hello down there!
This one.
There can't be too much in here.
I'd better save it.
Maybe we can take the pigeon now.
Already got some.
No, take him.
Must be little Michi.
Take him.
Does a birdie want a bone?
Birdie want a little treat?
Some calcium?
Manny is the kind of guy that saves an item to the end of
the game and never uses it.
That's also me.
I'm like, I can't use the thing.
What if I use it in 10 years from now?
This is a roguelike?
I can't use the thing.
What if I use it?
I gotta save it for the second game.
I gotta save it.
The letter.
What if, because it's a carrier pigeon.
Who will he take it to?
Deliver!
Okay, don't bite.
This is a note.
You like notes, remember?
already got some wait we gave it to him this pigeon's got my
scary note from Hector already got some so then oh well here
goes nothing go baby for the revolution oh yes and then yeah
we're
to scare the guy because i didn't notice earlier when i
checked oh my god no i was gonna say when i checked earlier
it didn't have a name on it you know like so it couldn't it
didn't say like manny it could be addressed to anybody
one of that was messengers with a message for me
i know what you're up to i've been watching I'm coming to
sprout to myself.
George truly, Hector LeMais.
I knew it!
I knew he was out to get me the old time!
Now he's definitely not gonna...
You're going to have to find my cigarette out, Hector.
You're going to have to find yourself another Flores!
Oh!
Is he okay?
Nice.
Yeah, we're in no hurry, Manny.
Come on.
Oh.
Flores is gone.
Is there still something in here hello down there oh never
mind go back to sleep whatever you are oh he's doing
push-ups you guys give me that
what is this
i need to see what's underneath here mister will it let me
see If I touched that stuff, I'd end up with morning-gloring
mittens.
Well, true.
The flakes of bone are sprouting when they hit the puddle
and turn it into baby tears.
Baby tears!
So that's how we find where he goes!
I saw Bowsley run down here.
Where did he go?
That's how we find out!
Yay!
Finally, our bone dust is useful!
Yippee!
Okay, hold on.
And...
Here.
There.
Hmm.
Bowsley's probably in that maze.
But I'd never be able to find him without...
Well, without something really helpful.
Yeah, I have it.
So go.
Bowsley's probably in that maze, but I'd never be able to
find him without, well, without something really helpful.
Really helpful.
Glottis?
I don't know how finicky is gonna be.
Is it because we're driving?
Oh, jeez.
Glottis, you're really helpful.
No use for it.
What do you mean no use for it?
For our friend.
What is this?
This remote control works for bone wagon suspension.
Watch the chrome.
Can I speak?
No use for it.
Why, don't call glottis an it?
Maybe you need to start at the beginning and do the whole
trail.
Oh, is that what we mean by finicky?
It could very well be.
Oh, geez.
No,
no, no, no, no, stop, stop.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
No, no, no.
Oh, my God.
Is this actually what I have to do?
I keep forgetting that.
I'm, like, moving with my mouse and my keyboard.
So I have to.
uh, make sure I, um, move my mouse a little bit.
I'm blocking it a little bit, but it stops, though.
Oh my god.
It's, like, the tiniest amount that works.
I heard something.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Pixel hunting for real?
Oh my god.
Okay.
No!
Please, I had it!
The sad music really adds to this.
Add to it, like...
You have to like do all this work.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Someone probably spent a year programming this.
I wonder if I can do from behind, like, this way.
Yes.
Do I have to do this one at a time?
For real, though?
I know I'm still at the entrance.
Okay, maybe I can, like, start following again.
Okay.
I was doing so well on the other side.
Maybe I can like just...
Oh.
No, no, no, no, stop, stop.
Maybe we can just guess.
No, stop!
The thing doesn't show up!
Oh, God.
What?
I can't tell what, like, the range is of this.
Stop!
I swear.
I swear I'm going to become the Joker.
Stop!
Can you press E or something instead of clicking?
The sprouting bone shows where Bowsley dripped the
concentrate as he ran.
No, uh, there might be another thing.
You don't need to make a complete line.
Okay, I just have to figure out where it goes.
But I'm kind of lost on this.
Ah, there it is, there it is.
Okay, we can guess, we can guess.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I love it.
I love being able to not see the next area.
Stop, please.
Okay.
All right.
You for use.
Oh, thank you so much.
You saved me.
You might have saved the run, you guys.
Oh.
So this one.
Or this way.
Thank God there's unlimited amounts of this guy's bone.
I did it!
Okay, I think I could follow the trail this way, but I need
a little light.
Yippee!
Hey, what's that?
Is that the monster?
That must be the floor's hideout.
No, not that.
The thing coming at us!
Ah!
Oh!
Oh.
Let's back up.
Wait.
Is this gonna get me?
I didn't save before going in.
It can't kill you?
Slowly coming towards us.
Oh, we can push him?
We can push him instead?
Yeah?
When he attacks us and then we attack him.
We...
What are we even reaching?
I'll turn it down.
Push!
I'm trying!
Forward!
What am I supposed to do?
Push!
Oh!
Like my mama always says, push, push, push!
Push, push, push, push!
the remote.
Oh, true.
Let's try it.
Now we're just scared and really tall.
Oh my god.
When I press you, that's when Mania said, I can't reach that
high.
Why was I able to push him so much before?
Wait, why am I going backwards now?
Wait, maybe...
I was trying to get his mouth or something.
I don't dude what
is happening i'm trying to squish him i'm trying i can't get
under him happens if you're back away it just comes at me
is there any oh that ledge looks like a safer place to be oh
maybe oh maybe we need to go over there
Maybe that's why it stops us over by that way.
Can we reach now?
There we go.
Make a run for it, never mind.
Crap, crap.
Can I pour this on him?
This is the perfect time to use it!
What are we talking about?
Oh, you're supposed to- Wait.
Now I can squish him with his tail is turned.
It showed his tail.
Please, where is it?
Ouch!
Okay, now I can go.
Oh, wait, nope, save.
Oh, not load, save, save.
Okay.
Maybe I give it to him now?
Maybe we don't give it to him at all.
Maybe we actually just leave.
Sorry, Glottis.
Take care of that for me if he could.
I guess.
He's got a gun.
Hector is the Jew?
You better back off, man.
I mean it.
I'm not feeling too rosy.
I'm heavy.
I'm thinking I better.
Things are gonna change around here!
Yeah, man.
Just run at him.
Hi!
Listen, Bowsley, I'm not here to hurt you.
It's not Hector.
It's Manny Calavera.
Do you know me?
Hey.
It's Manny Calavera come to sprout ya.
To bear back off, man.
What's that?
What are you doing?
Are you crazy?
Get back.
Put your hands over your head.
your hands put your head on your lap I mean it I'm not
feeling too rosy okay I'm having I feel what do we need to
do I'm thinking I better that's the most gruesome window
display I've ever seen hey I'm not touching any of these
human remains why not display I'm not touched this human
remains sane their southern shut what's out of there looks
like a big ball of tape screwed to the wall can't Let's go
to the world!
Things are gonna change around here!
Yeah, man.
I'll just, uh...
You won't.
Who do you think you're fooling?
Hey, you know what you just did?
You just opened Pandora's box!
Wait, why?
Right now, I'll let you have it.
I'll...
Oh.
Hello?
Hey there, stranger.
Can I help you?
It broke him out of his psychosis!
Because we were like a customer instead!
Sure.
Alright, here you go.
You have a great day now.
Oh, okay!
Why did we- we came from the wall?
Puzzle solved.
I don't know how we got past that gator, but, uh...
Awesome.
Oh, wait.
Now, is that it?
I did it?
Don't think about it.
I was wondering if maybe the bell...
Like, I thought that...
Like, I thought maybe the bell would, like, be the thing
for...
Like, he would hear it and be like, oh, I'm back in my old
shop, you know?
But I didn't think that was the actual answer.
Now, we are armed.
We are ready to go see Hector.
Hello.
I'm here to conduct visits with Hector Lamonts.
I just spoke with him on the phone and he's expecting me.
You know Hector Lamonts, huh?
Yeah.
Then answer me this one simple question.
Yes.
Okay.
How many times has Hector Lamonts unsuccessfully run for
mayor?
Unsuccessfully?
I would say zero because he's the mayor.
Yeah, we came through the wall.
Are we ghosts?
Did the gator get us?
Wait, did he...
Are we supposed to know this or are we supposed to guess?
Wait, there's...
What kind of question is that?
Oh, sorry.
I guess you don't know Hector Lamans like I know Hector
Lamans.
Look at the wall.
Wait, you guys saw him?
Oh!
What is the circumference of Hector Lamont's head in inches?
Which one would it be?
Is circumference in inches?
Is it 34?
24, 32?
34?
Oh, sorry.
know hector lamans like i know hector lamans why do you know
his head circumference let's go buddy oh these ones are okay
okay how many stones might an englishman say that hector
lamans weighs oh they're different uh 27 27 27 stone oh 34
is a big head look we might he might be a exaggerating he
might be embellishing the truth a little bit to make people
think that he has a really big smart brain 27 stone is crazy
how much in freedom units how much is that 27 yeah well that
was an easy one too bad I win best two out of three don't
mess with me I know to Le Mans.
What the?
Uh, well, I'm gonna save.
How conveniently placed answer, right?
Yeah, it's very easy.
One stone is 14 pounds.
14 times 20.
That's a lot.
Guys, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna go get some more water.
I have a smaller mug today.
So...
And I was already drinking it...
Before...
Before stream.
So I'll be right back.
Right back, right back.
Guys, something sad happened today.
I have a little cup that I always use it as decoration more
than anything.
I think I might have used it once or twice.
But I went to go wash it because a lot of my stuff coming
out from the boxes was like mega, mega dusty.
And so I went to go wash it today and I opened up the lid,
which was made of wood.
And there was mold all underneath it.
And I was like, no!
So I was like, that's okay.
Anyway, like, it's like a decorative cup, you know.
I had a very cute design on it that I really liked.
So I was like, well, I'll throw away the lid.
And I will.
I'll just use the cup itself.
And then I was like, oh, well, the cup touched the mold.
And I usually handwash all my dishes.
But I was like, I'll get it extra good.
I'll put it in the dishwasher.
and I put it in the dishwasher and I took it out like about
an hour before stream and it completely destroyed the design
yeah so I ruined the cup in two ways in the same day I'm so
sad not dishwasher safe If it was not...
Two for one deal!
Inspired by...
Inspired by Grim Fandango.
And I'm gonna display my cute mugs instead.
No.
At least the mold is gone though.
Yeah.
Oh well.
I've done that to a color change.
No!
Not the sippy cup!
It was kind of a sippy cup, but not really.
It had a straw.
I guess you're sipping through a straw.
In the future, vinegar is excellent against mold.
Yeah, but I don't know how long the mold was there for.
And also, it seemed that the wood was very porous.
So I would be afraid of using it.
Or keeping it.
If like, I don't know if it's going to get rid of the mold
entirely.
So too bad, too bad.
Oh my gosh, my friend had a color changing mug.
Except, oh my gosh, wait.
Maybe I don't say this, in case I want it for merch in the
future.
Well, I won't do this merch.
My friend had a color-changing mug.
It was, it was a, it was like, wait, who was it?
Maybe it, maybe it's not who I was thinking it was.
But, um, it was an anime girl in a bathtub, but the bubbles
were black.
like colored black and then when you pour it in hot water it
would get rid of the bubbles and you would see the naked
anime girl it's so awesome
it's so awesome i'd like that as merch how can i use it
though i can't be naked that's freaky and i've already
released a mug Which I never got.
I want to release more dishes though.
Since I collect anime dishes, I want to release more like
forks and knives and cups and plates and things like that.
Too freaky even for you?
Maybe.
Yeah, probably.
I'm not the freaky one.
In that way.
I just have a freaky thought.
You know?
I just have the freaky thoughts.
I'm not the freaky one.
You know what I mean?
I don't want the freak to happen to me.
But you are freak phantom.
Yeah, but it's different.
It's different.
It's different, it's different, it's different.
It's funny because I feel like people have a very
conflicting image of me.
Sometimes I hear people being like, oh no, I'm too innocent.
And then some people, they'll be like shocked when I talk
about Eroge and and my Dojin Shi.
And then there's some people that think I'm like, I'm naked
in the streets.
I think the image of me is very polarizing.
I don't think I've ever been naked in the streets before.
Well, who's the freakier one?
The buyer or the seller?
The answer is you, no matter what.
What do you mean?
Never change, Minto.
So you...
I mean, you never say you don't stream naked.
You can see I'm wearing clothes right now.
I've always got my clothes on.
Anyway, let's keep going.
Oh, hello?
Celso Flores, what are you doing in Hector Lamar's waiting
room?
Oh, he sent us out here to make up our minds about his
offer.
Who are you?
If you don't mind me asking.
Oh.
Is this your wife?
Is this your wife, Selso?
Yes, we've just returned from a lovely cruise.
Well, it became lovely once I caught up with you, my little
tamale.
Wait, this is the guy that worked at the restaurant, no?
Oh, yeah, and what's beneath those clothes?
That's for me to know and you'd not find out.
Hello, welcome to Babusha, thank you.
You're very freaky, but you don't always pick up on
innuendo.
so people think you're innocent.
Maybe.
You don't think you've been naked in the streets?
I don't think so, but I don't know what I do when I'm
asleep.
What if he did the mug idea with the red dress?
That'd be sick, right?
Wait, it's your client from the opening cutscene.
Oh, oh, I thought it was the guy who had the mop.
Unless that was him, too.
Oh.
I'm your travel agent.
Oh, I have a travel agent already.
But he's miles away mopping floors in an automat, so I
suppose the position is open.
Oh, it's the same guy.
Okay.
Actually, I work for Hector.
He sent me to answer your questions.
Eh, I'll handle this, my sweet one.
Wait, so...
What can you tell me about these double-end tickets?
This price seems much more than double.
So, is this...
the lady that he was waiting for because like remember she
was spotted with another guy oh do we do we be honest
they cost a mint but they save you a mint it's his wife
can i save you save here it's a scam the are counterfeit
take your money and run oh don't try any of that tricky
reverse psychology on me never mind okay you deserve it what
exactly are you saving what exactly are you saving your
money for a rainy day because let me tell you you're dead
every day is raining from now on yes but there's no reason
not to be careful with your money sure sure well they cost
the mint because they they save you a mint well I don't have
a mint so what do I care we refuse things that cost a mint
we will never give up our mint yeah bro is cooked he's so
stupid the real question is don't you feel you're worth it I
know we're worth it but are the tickets worth it enough
about you guys let me tell you about my problems actually we
have a lot of talking we need to do so This makeup breathes
about as much as Volcanized Rubber.
I can't raise my arm.
I can't raise my arms in this suit.
Well, let's just hope no one pulls a gun on you tonight,
huh?
I just got back from the worst vacation!
I just got back from the worst vacation I've ever had.
Actually, I just got back from quite an adventure myself.
So, well, I'm sure you've seen flying spiders and flaming
beavers, but trust me, it gets worse.
the edge of the world and back and then the game starts over
again and we do again traveling the land of the dead was so
fraught with peril now how much would you pay just to skip
the whole thing darling come let us blow our nest egg
together whoa mr.
labans we've decided to take you up on your generous offer
excellent excellent the little lady changed your mind no
actually it was your agent over there of course he's one of
my best well come on in let's chat shall we still got it
wait can I go in hello I don't know who you are and I don't
know what spell you cast on the florist couple but stick
around once I'm done with them there's something across town
I'd like to show you sure it's it am I talking about just a
job here or am i talking about opportunity in the general
sector is huge oh my god no wonder he wore is it weighed 27
stone or whatever we've had trouble filling them i could
really use a closer like you on the team oh domino is gone
this could be your office i've had bigger yeah try this on
see how it feels that's yours too and as an added bonus 2%
of these, Mr. My name is Calavera, and I want a bigger cup.
Mr. Calavera, I'm going to need most of these to get myself
out of this world.
You see, I've been a very bad boy.
I'm going to deliver those tickets to their rightful owners,
and I'm going to deliver you to the compost pile.
Aye.
Wait, was that our only bullet?
It couldn't have...
Don't turn your back on him.
Oh my gosh!
It's too heavy!
Oh my god, the machine is breaking!
Oh!
Wait, that's it?
No.
Loser music.
Weeweeweeweeweeweewee.
This is really the old place, isn't it now?
Hello?
Pigeons?
Friends now?
I bet I could get over to the other roof on the leg of this
sign, but the legs pointed too far down and it looks like
Hector blew the motor.
Yeah, he did.
Is there any, oh, any pigeons over here?
I like that we're in our original outfit now.
Paint it!
We still have that?
We still have our grinder?
We got our gun?
Hmm, this gun might actually look nice with a little baby's
breath.
It's cracked, but still stronger than me.
Uh...
What do we got?
Is this it?
For some reason?
There can't be too much in here.
I'd better save it.
If it's cracked...
What should we use?
It's sprout teller, not spackle.
Oh, okay.
Freeze and break?
Maybe we...
Here we go.
And then...
It's still useful.
The bone is still useful.
It's sprout teller, not spackle.
Come on!
My gun doesn't need reloading yet.
Maybe we use the gun instead.
I'm saving my ammo for the big guy.
Well, you have, like, so much ammo.
The music's so good.
I think your idea was actually right.
Wait, really?
I bet I could get over to the other roof on the leg of the
sign.
but the legs pointed too far down and it looks like hector
blew the motor maybe i um didn't like sprinkle the thing
right then oh it is what the heck maybe i didn't sprinkle it
right then it's a bone chipper now yeah maybe if i do it
like that well so much for my third arm oh it's gone it's
gone my third arm
There we go.
Well, it was going to happen eventually.
He's made it.
He's turned this place into Vegas.
I take it back.
Ay Chihuahua!
She got hers back.
That one must be yours.
Don't forget to send for help.
I have no way I asked for your game or subs code.
No!
I forgot because I got too excited.
I ordered more.
Thank you!
It's okay, you didn't have to do that!
Thank Gladys!
Get in, quick.
Wait, how do we can trust you?
We were supposed to have coverage back there.
Where are all of Salvador's men?
I don't know.
He hasn't told me yet.
it oh man he should have been screaming time for you to
swing daddy oh let's see you walk
oh man these flowers all people hector has sprouted hey when
you're on top like my boyfriend hector is you make a lot of
enemies boyfriend hector when did this happen
You know you really have bad taste in men.
No, I have a taste for really bad men.
There's a difference.
Oh, oh, oh.
I thought I told you to scat man.
Is she gonna kill me if I keep talking to her?
You gonna get me?
Get me, get me, get me, get me.
Look, tiptoe through the tulips already.
I know I have a taste in bad men.
Hey baby, take all the time you want.
But you gotta go face the music sooner or later.
Alright,
go running.
Off into the distance.
What is this thing?
Hmm.
Hector supplies water to keep the flowers alive?
Does he see them as a memorial?
or as trophies oh that's freaky not thirsty can I put my can
I put this in there there can't be too much oh come on
whatever whatever we're gonna use this eventually we have to
knock
knock she loves me she loves me not well you're half right
oh Manny so cynical what happened to you many that caused
you to lose your sense of hope your love of life I died I
see I guess Domino is right you don't have a shred of
optimism well when it comes to shreds Dom is the expert and
by that same logic Manny you're about to become an expert in
botany is this where you tell me all about your secret plan
hector i don't think it's a secret double intake is from
innocent souls pretended to sell them but really hoarded
them all for yourself in a desperate attempt to get out of
the land of the dead i don't think he wants out no this is
where you'll rise around in excruciating pain for about an
hour because that idiot bowels they ran off with all their
fast acting sprout very slow stuff we'll sprout you but it's
going to take a long time i'm sorry to say
manny where are you going you've got some time you know
before you have to leave get it leave the way he speaks is
so Oh my god.
This time!
Please, let me use it!
Finally.
Toto Santos.
Oh, we walk it off.
We walk it off.
Come on.
Shake it for me, baby.
One of you must be mine.
We walk it off.
Wait, what do we have left?
Yoink the car.
yeah I'm about to
oh Salvador Manuel listen carefully there's a gun in the
trunk of this car but the trunk key is with my body
somewhere in the meadow behind the greenhouse find it right
and tell Eva that I know she will guide the Alliance wisely
when I am gone for when I bite this explosive tooth the
deadly cloud will sprout not just my target but me as well
your target what are you hey get out of there farewell my
friend What were you talking about with the head of the LSA
in there?
Uh-oh.
We gotta get out of here.
Got something you want to share with the class?
Only this.
Oh my god!
Sacrifice!
He truly gave his body to the cause.
Can I take him home?
picking that up okay it's not that it's Salvador he's fine
right where he is oh my god okay so the body is behind the
greenhouse too soon man he is so cold-hearted you're not
picking that up you're gonna extract him
This is the trunk, the trunk, right?
Wait, where are we?
I guess we didn't get very far, huh?
But no, we can't open the trunk.
I'm stupid.
Sorry.
We can't open the trunk without the key.
After I deal with Hector.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go over this way.
La, la, la.
Running, running, running.
Got in the trunk, key with the body.
Exactly, exactly.
We can use more of this!
We can!
I still feel like we can poison the water supply.
It's all gone.
But the water's all gone?
Oh, wait, this is all gone?
The stuff is all gone?
It's all gone.
Oh, just kidding.
It sounds like it's still there.
It would evaporate.
In the water?
Alright.
I don't think...
I like to save because...
Because what if there's like a thing to...
That can change an outcome, you know?
This is the way in.
I just hope there's a way out.
Oh, yeah, we got...
He's walking all on his own, you guys.
I'm not touching anything.
Now I'm touching something.
Now I'm controlling him.
Can we not get around?
This way?
Wait, stop it, stop it.
I want to see this angle, please.
He's possessed!
Natural reaction, you know?
Aww.
Okay, we can't.
Seems like we can't do anything.
I guess let's just go in.
No, don't turn and look at me.
Go on in!
I'm not going in there until I'm packing some chlorophyll.
Oh, I guess she took our gun, huh?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
So we do have to go back behind.
A little bit this way.
But it, like, won't let me.
Okay, I'm just gonna follow the invisible wall.
Eh?
There we go.
Oh, I did it, I did it, I did it.
Okay.
Behind?
Uh.
He said the body was behind the shed, no?
Did he say the shed of the greenhouse?
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
We'll go.
We're super fast.
We're super speed.
It's not a shed that's a water tower.
It's all we've got, though.
It's all we've got.
or not
there's something you need to locate his body is there now
okay let's check the car again
I wonder if he had a ticket
maybe we can use a ticket to find his body
after I deal with Hector no no hey my scythe Well, what do
you know?
Sal had a ticket all alone.
No.
Not picking that up.
No, take the ticket, you dummy.
It's amazing how Salvador's ticket is still drawn to him.
Maybe if you take his ticket with his body, if you take his
body, you know, you'll be able to find him.
You know what I mean?
I'm not finding him.
I've said the wrong thing.
He will be able to move on.
You know what I mean?
If you take his body with you to the afterlife, after
afterlife, he can move on because, you know, it didn't
matter.
He still was able to go with his body.
My brain was thinking of one thing.
Find the body.
So I said the wrong thing.
But that's what I meant.
We're gonna find them.
Seems to be attracted to something over this way.
It's not doing anything now.
You're hot?
You're cold?
Oh.
Yippee!
Finding a needle in a haystack, baby.
Oh.
this must be the key to Salvador's trunk can we take him I
already searched him pretty thoroughly oh seven Salvador
he's fine right where he is you're so mean Maddie you're so
mean you're heartless a girl
The perfect burial on the surface without a head.
Ah, yes.
Lots of ammo.
And the gun?
Do we have to get it from her?
Freeze, Hector.
Yeah, you heard me.
Oh, now we're role playing.
Okay, good.
Let's go.
Let's go?
No, uh, sure.
You can go that way.
Why'd you stop?
Manny, I was drinking water.
You need to go up there.
Why are we over here?
Manny, Manny, you know where you need to go.
But, uh, I'm so tiny.
Okay.
These cinematic, these cinematic shots are really doing it
for me.
All right, here we go.
I'm not getting any closer until he runs out of ammo.
If he runs out of ammo, that is.
We have to get him to run out of ammo now.
Do we, like, go tap on the window or something?
Hello?
Hey!
Hector, look at me!
Break it down!
outside.
Oh,
now I'm really breaking it down.
Go Manny, go Manny, it's your birthday, it's your birthday,
we're gonna party like it's your birthday, it's your dead
day, it's your dead day, we're gonna party like it's your
dead day.
Go Skelly, go Skelly, go Skelly, break it down, break it
down.
Don't break a bone, but break it down.
Oh, Skelly.
Go Skelly.
Go Manny.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, hey, Hector, look at this.
Hector!
He's like, did you really just make me do that?
I don't want to mess up my blade.
I don't know how to make him shoot.
I don't want to miss up my blade.
Oh.
Hopefully you don't need your blade for much longer, huh?
You have a gun.
But he literally said he won't go in until...
What does Dave shoot?
You will miss the best line.
I've missed lines sometimes.
I've never played the game before.
I'm not getting...
any closer until he runs out of ammo can we shoot him from
here it won't even let me interact with him that's why
that's why I'm confused oh
yeah oh yeah round two back at it new moves new me same
robes let's go this old sack of bones got new moves to show
oh yeah break it down I'm Manny let's go
I'm not getting any closer until he runs out of ammo.
If he runs out of ammo, that is.
I remember you could shoot at him from outside the window.
I don't know what to tell you, guys.
You can see that I can't interact with him at all.
Oh.
You can see I can't interact with him.
Even when I had the gun out.
I don't know what to tell you.
you guys oh
there's one olivia who's out there i'm the grim reaper lard
ass and you're my next customer shouldn't you be a batch of
posies by now
oh yeah holy nice try i wonder if i have to like Oh, I don't
want to get...
Oh.
Wait, where are you going, Ben?
Manny, go back!
Oh.
Watch this, Hector!
Old robe, new moves.
I'm a...
Manny, the grim reaper.
I'm here to reap your soul.
You'll never see it coming.
Check it out.
Check these moves.
I'm jumping and to the groove.
I don't know anymore.
Come on, Shorty.
People who live in glass houses get pretty good at ducking,
I see.
Is that your best?
Ho ho ho ho!
Jolly good time!
Ho ho ho ho ho!
Ho ho ho!
Man, he's solving it via dance-off.
Why?
Why can't we just have a dance-off?
Ooh, that would have gotten him.
That would have gotten him.
Is he gonna run out of ammo?
You can't escape the grim reaper, Hector.
Especially not when he's got a gun.
Ha!
You're on a downhill disadvantage, Manny.
I've got ammo in here for five years.
Five years!
Closer!
Hmm.
Might be something else you need to do.
Yeah, but I like shooting the gun too.
Oh!
Hmm.
I'm just kind of trying to...
I'm aiming for the windows.
That is a lot of bullets.
Oh, good.
We got another one.
Battleship, battleship.
Oh, how did we get up there?
That's for Salvador.
Over here, Andy Oakley.
Is that your best?
Oh,
over there.
Come on, Shorty.
Shorty!
Up there.
Nice try.
Can I go in?
I'm not getting any clothes.
until he runs out of ammo.
How am I supposed to have...
He just said he's gonna have ammo for five years.
Just get real close.
Woo!
Hmm.
What else we got here?
The music is creepy.
Time to find the LucasArts solution.
Do you think I do actually have to cut off the water supply?
So the flower stopped growing for five years?
Oh, I just put it away.
I thought I used it.
I pressed the wrong button.
I was like, oh dang, it was right.
Oops.
Whoopsie.
I don't want to mess up my blade.
My scythe.
I like to keep it next to where my heart used to be.
I don't want to miss up my bleed.
I say we, like, put the sprout seed into the water supply or
something, and then catch it on fire, and then the water
sprays, and he gets sprouted.
Oh, gun?
Shoot it.
Oh, so true.
Whoa, he just...
Slid down the hill.
That was pretty cool.
You're pretty cool, Manny.
You're pretty cool.
Maybe I had the right idea.
Maybe I had the right idea after all.
That doesn't sound good.
sound good.
Should we go in there?
I don't know about that.
Oh, but we made lots of holes.
We made lots of holes, so the gas shouldn't, it should
release, you know?
Oh, that's a lot of... Is that him?
Is that a lot of Hector?
Oh, we didn't even get to shoot him.
No.
way is
he confused this is where we get off isn't it you can count
them if you want they're all here how about yours the
company gave me one on the other end sort of a retirement
prison and demons ride free right oh man you know I can't go
with you I'm a spirit of the land and all that I can't ever
leave this world I guess I got so wrapped up in saving
people I I just assume I'd be able to save you too.
Yeah, but I don't need to be saved.
Yeah, he doesn't need to be saved.
I've been here.
I'm not all alone in that basement anymore, thanks to you.
I got a new job and all these new friends.
I'm a big demon's success story.
So, I guess this is it then.
The music is so funny for...
Come here, give me a hug.
Oh!
You were the best boss I ever had.
Bye.
I mean, you're too cute.
Baby glottises!
Manny?
Yeah?
When we get to the next world...
What is it, Angel?
Are we going to be together?
You know, sweetheart, if there's one thing I've learned,
it's this.
Nobody knows what's going to happen at the end of the line.
So you might as well enjoy the trip.
Ooh la la!
So we had a ticket after all!
For our friend Jepeth?
Aww.
That's it!
Oh my god!
We did it!
From my childhood, my dad would randomly say, My scythe, I
like to keep it where my heart used to be, so this game
holds a special place for me.
Oh, congrats on feeding the gamito.
Counselor, thank you!
So many people died!
So, I wonder what happened to Eva.
Shadow!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
What happened to the whole world?
Who picks it up after Hector is dead?
Dead died.
Resign the Trace, thank you for the...
For Hector dead.
Favorite character?
Glottis.
I love Glottis.
I also like the two little angel kids.
That was so fun.
Glottis MVP.
Yeah.
That guy's awesome.
I also like the Gator.
Yeah!
Time to write fanfic of the world afterwards.
Yeah, yeah.
I like that he finished it in his Reaper outfit.
That was pretty sick.
He reaped Hector.
Carla was your favorite.
Spang!
Thank you for this super good!
Pretty good.
There's some janky puzzles, but it's got a really strong
writing.
I agree, I agree.
Thank you guys for all the little hints and helps for some
of the puzzles.
But this was great!
This was so awesome.
I love point and click games.
The lead writer director made his own studio after this
game.
It's called Double Fine.
And all their games are great.
Oh, check it out!
What is it?
Double Fine.
That's similar to a fashion brand that I like.
So I think I can remember the name.
Wait, they did Cyclonauts!
What?
Wait, that's crazy.
Yeah, even I know Cyclonauts.
I've never played it, but even I know that one.
Monkey Island games are a good time, too.
Hold on.
This song, this is, this is, this is great.
I'm gonna swing to this.
Andrew goes, thank you for the luck of the food!
Congrats on finishing one of my favorite games ever!
I had a lot of fun watching you play it someday.
You should play Monkey Island series.
Echonuts, Echonuts, two.
More nuts.
Salmon Max.
Yeah, I think I have that on my list of games I want to play
eventually, but finding a way to play it, I think is not the
easy part.
Congrats on the wins of these puzzles were special.
You were officially pixel perfect.
Did you know Donna Burke did a song in DDR?
Wait, she did?
Which one?
Darko, thank you so much for the peek.
Thank you so much for playing my favorite game.
I hope it leaves you with lots of chew on like it did for
me.
It's a really good dev commentary mode.
I saw the dev commentary.
Skeletons, thank you!
Oh, they did remasters for the Salmon Max games.
Oh, okay, okay.
This game was great.
It's so fun seeing the little glottlings at the end.
I know!
They're so cute!
Oh, it's so cute!
Stargate, Heaven, and Supernova.
Oh, check it out then.
Wait, and Supernova, I've played that one.
What's up, Jellybee?
Thank you for that support, too.
Good job, Minto.
It was nice to see this playthrough and didn't seem to tax
the sanity too hard.
No cannibalism today.
Barely.
I really thought we were gonna put the bones in the coffee.
I thought we were gonna put the bones in the coffee.
And then they'd be like, I don't know.
Coffee's really salty today.
Or something.
We were so close.
Are you disappointed?
Yeah.
You know, though, honestly, Hector could have had a thriving
tea business with all those flowers.
Guy wasn't thinking big enough
Calcium enriched coffee You know how everything's kind of in
it We're in the protein phase Everything's got protein in it
right now Popcorn's got protein Matcha's got protein
Everything's got protein right now We're gonna move on to
the calcium phase one day We're all gonna be like little
geckos When I had a gecko, when you would have the crickets
and the mealworms, you could pour, you would pour like a
calcium powder on them to help the, help the geckos get more
calcium.
So that's what's going to be all of us.
I saw a protein salad at the store today.
What does that?
Just, just, just put some, something in it.
Put some protein in it.
Become as Lizard.
Lizard.
Yeah, there's protein in everything nowadays.
But guys, don't forget to have your fiber or you're going to
end up like Manny over here.
Dead.
So be careful.
Have your fiber.
I just had protein granola and protein yogurt.
My breakfast was a couple of protein shakes.
I think I have a protein problem.
Darko!
You have to also have fiber with it!
Manny died from protein poisoning.
No!
One thing, though, I kind of wish we had seen the land of
the living a little bit more.
When they showed that first time when we got Meche, of the
living stuff because it was so freaky i like that part a lot
yeah the people there freaked me out they did it was freaky
it was creepy i liked it i kept thinking about it i was like
i hope we get to more land of the living in the original
design document you have to visit your brother in the land
to the living.
That's awesome.
The granola gives fiber?
I'm sure it's fine.
As others mentioned, Secret of Monkey Island is amazing
point and click.
As are the missed sequels.
Yeah, Nancy Drew.
I love Nancy Drew.
Psychonauts not point and click is amazing, though.
What is Psychonauts like hold on?
Is it on Steam?
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
It's playing.
oh we get the opening wait those are the four guys that took
us out sorry for the wait mr flores i am ready to take you
now take me take me where now take me where there's no need
to be nervous nervous oh no just your appearance it's summer
camp the game intimidating story heavy platformer wait that
sounds awesome my name's manny calavera i'm your new travel
agent i don't I'm just gonna skip this because...
Wait, wait, I don't feel like we need to listen to it.
Hmm, what is this?
I have the original design doc on my PC.
Tim Schaefer released it around the time this remaster was
released.
Oh, neat!
Neat, neat, neat.
I'm glad you guys like...
I'm glad you guys like point-and-click adventure games,
because I do too.
They're so fun!
Maybe we give Psychonauts a try then.
since I've never played it before.
It's a game that I've always seen, you know?
It's one of those types of games where it's like...
So many people have heard of it, but...
You know.
I've never played it.
It's worth?
Yeah?
Hmm.
Well, I should make like a master...
or something on YouTube that I could be like, hey, send me a
point-and-click games because everybody always suggests
things and then I, I, uh, what's the word?
I, uh, forget them.
Cause, uh, cause I am like reading chat.
I for a goar.
This is a long list.
Yeah.
People always tell me in chat, but chat moves and my brain
moves too.
You wouldn't believe it, but my brain does move.
I haven't done Monkey Island, no, no.
Yeah.
Yay!
This was so fun!
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
I'm gonna go take this time to get me some dinner.
Brutal Legend is also a great game developed by Double Fine,
voiced by Jack Black!
No way!
Thank you again for the super chat!
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you.
It's always fun, my dear Minto!
Yeah!
I'm still getting used to my new afterlife in this new made
cafe, but...
I'm almost done setting up my main stuff.
Right now, I think I have everything unpacked that is
essentials and kind of just unpacking my decorations now
slowly.
But streams should return to more normal soon, soon, soon.
I've been getting so many comments.
You guys would not believe the amount of comments I get
being like, gonna play Alan Wake 2?
Where's Alan Wake 2?
Alan Wake 2!
So I think, I mean I did want to play Alan Wake 2 after
Deadly Premonition.
So just a little while longer.
Patience, Yako.
Yeah.
Alan Wake 2.
I have not played Control.
And honestly, I did want to play control before Alan wake
too, but the people will not leave me alone.
The people will not leave me alone.
We'll see.
We'll see, though.
Please do it despite of the people.
Well, like I said, we gotta get through deadly premonition
first anyway.
But then, after that, I probably pick up another story game
to play.
One!
Spake, thank you, Resync Latrice, thank you!
Come back, Owa!
Wait, I was just finishing up.
I saw you said that you played Slay the Spire for a long,
lot of time.
that you said so.
She's addicted.
What?
I think you guys are all the gifted!
Thank you for all the gifted memberships.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
She's got an addiction.
I want to... She makes me want to play it, though.
It's addictive!
You make me want to play it.
Didn't Slay the Spy or two come out like... Wait, are you
playing Slay the Spy or two or one?
Which one is she playing, you guys?
Because didn't Slay the Spire 2, like, come out last year,
the year before last or something?
Oh, she's playing 2.
It's a multiplayer!
No way.
Wait, Slay the Spire 2.
Oh, they're both the same prize.
It has co-op.
That sounds pretty fun.
I'll learn how to play if you ever want a partner to me.
Oh, it's early access.
Oh, wait.
I said last year.
It was literally earlier this year.
That's crazy.
Nice.
Let's do it.
Let's do it!
We could get two other people.
We could have a Green Girls collab or something.
but yeah um i just beat i just beat grim fandango everybody
it was really awesome um it was so so good highly recommend
super duper recommend what we can do is raid into doki
because she is streaming about her stuff from la and we
performed with her so uh we being sloppy sisters um oh nimi
too though yeah that's right me too so we can reign into
doki doki bird oh there she is thank you everybody oh it's a
beat oh thank you thank you thank you have a good day have a
good night and I'll see you when I see you next bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye See you, see you, see you, bye, bye,
bye.
I wanted to mention, too, that, like, with my stream
schedule, and, like, me, still getting used to stuff, I
wanna, I wanna chit-chat with you guys more and everything.
I just, you know, after stream, I've been using the time to
do a little bit more work and unpacking and things, so,
hopefully once I'm more in a, in a, uh, uh, a less state of
craziness.
I still have boxes everywhere.
so then we can chat and hang out some for some longer so
sorry but soon yeah thank you guys bye bye
oh i'm surrounded by lizards UGH!
UGH!